vous le savez j'ai été le sujet d'un
article de presse a fait longtemps que
vous parle de ce reportage qu'on a fait
il paraît que voilà je terrorisent mes
équipes parfois est ce que je vous ai
terrorisé jamais voilà si surtout belaïd
un jour j'ai fait du chantage à la
boulette j'ai découvert qu'il y avait
même eu un reportage à charge qui avait
été fait sur les coulisses de touche pas
à mon poste je vais vous le faire
découvrir fo sont plus là julien donc il
connaît bien les missions
regardez je vous le dis j'ai rien à
cacher je vous montre tout regarder ça
et vous réagissez après pour le public
cyril hanouna est un animateur souriant
drôle et sympathique mais en coulisses
c'est une autre paire de manches
certains collaborateurs de celui que
l'on surnomme le diable de tunis ont
décidé de témoigner de leur enfer
quotidien lionel stan que nous
appellerons boris afin de préserver son
anonymat a décidé lui aussi de nous
parler de l'agression physique qu'il a
vécu un jour on était en réunion et
cyrine il arrive m'apporte un café je
n'avais rien demandé moi et en plus je
ne vois jamais de café c'est vraiment un
malade selon un chroniqueur a lui aussi
décidé de franchir le pas et de parler à
visage découvert c'est un malade ce mec
une fait venir tous les soirs sur le
plateau alors c'est très bien que je
capte rien n'a rien et on paye en plus
pour ça la seule personne n'ayant aucun
problème avec cyril hanouna se nomme
philippe plan car il est le responsable
qui gère l'arrivée de l'animateur
vedette dans les locaux de ses 8
alors je suis désolé mais à la chaîne
nous on est vraiment ravis d'accueillir
cyril parmi nous c'est une personne qui
est adorable c'est une personne très
gentille et à bâtir justement
débarque à ces délicieux moment avec
toit sert il merci le rejoindre mais
c'est le but le bienvenue chez toi et
très très vite pour de superno barca
[Musique]